[Musique]
c'est le fameux camion le fameux c'est
charlotte et voilà des pistes qu'il ya
beaucoup de chance on a tout ce qu'il
faut pour faire une belle puisque c'est
qu'ils charlotte sur lot la meilleure
question lancé la patronne elle
participé grandement l'automne dernier
clément karen et leur charlotte bien sûr
on me thru ce projet d'épicerie
ambulante qui sillonne les routes de
brome missisquoi
là nous ce qu'on voulait c'est d'aller
chez le client dans sa cour on ouvre le
camion et le client fait ses courses
comme s'ils étaient dans une épicerie
ça va donner vraiment l'accessibilité à
manger local à l'année à toutes les
femmes et qui nous sont dans notre
région en font c'est tellement vieux
comme le monde
les marchands ambulants des colporteurs
qui ont sillonné les rues des villes il
y avait des camions qui se présente avec
des fruits et légumes puis des fois on
pouvait vendre même quelques vêtements
pour on pouvait vendre un petit peu de
viande mais en général chacun avait sa
spécialité c'est presqu'une fait pour
certains quand tu arrives et le libre
c'était une fête surtout quand le livre
a le boulanger arrivé avec les galettes
avec les biscuits
on a tendance à l'oublier mais ya eu des
livreurs de lait qui passait en voiture
à cheval à montréal et à québec par
exemple jusqu'au début des années 1960
cela dit si on pense à des petites
villes en région
la livraison du lait la livraison du
pain va se perpétuer jusqu'aux années
1980 et même au delà dans certains coins
qu'est ce qui vous manque pour commencer
votre journée
alors c'est ça il me manque des légumes
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je suis
venu chez gilles notre chat ou ben
chercher l'ensemble de l'est des légumes
manquants et tantôt cent vallées à la
boucherie pour récupérer toutes les
boucheries charcuteries
[Musique]
allo gilles bonjour paiement va bien oui
c'est tout ma commande
c'est des tomates cerises et tomates
raisins sportif et ça c'est un très beau
projet j'aime beaucoup l'idée de la
cantine qui vaut porter nos légumes à
différents endroits et en même temps ça
permet de faire connaître nos légumes
bio
nous ne plan d'affaires est vraiment de
vendre le plus local possible et
on fait pas à faire des distributeurs
ont fait vraiment à faire avec des
marchés locaux des petits marchés l'eau
ta commande et complète perdent pas
merci
[Musique]
est ce que vous venez chercher
aujourd'hui ça me coûte combien d'un
vous allez avoir suffisamment de
matériau trois jours en trois jours à la
voir tourner mais je vous en avais
beaucoup le reste des médecins j'ai
trois frigos dans le camion
j'en ai un pour la vitrine et j'en ai
deux dans la réserve
[Musique]
alain natali ça va oui j'assume à
préparer aujourd'hui c'est non non
j'étais père des saucisses italiennes
fois paré boeuf c'est que les maquis m'a
approché moi j'allais vu passer beaucoup
sur facebook puis j'aime bien sûr l'idée
de se promener de ville envie d'aller
chercher les producteurs essaient d un
manteau du québec dans le conte à brome
missisquoi
c'est vraiment essentielle mal des
produits sébastien je vais payer combien
plus cher que si je m'étais déplacé pour
aller à la boucherie 0 vous allez payer
le même prix qu'à la bouche sa peau
c'est une entente avec les différents
producteurs nos différents
transformateur où l'abbé effectivement
on va on va avoir une cote entre
guillemets on va avoir une petite
réduction au niveau du du prix de vente
et ce qui permit d'à côté des choses je
pense que les tout premiers clients est
aussi faux que nous de découvrir
d'autres produits locaux
[Musique]
à
j'ai des frises et de la beauce ton on a
du tales aussi les steelers sont les
plus croustillantes qu'on a vu toutes
les semaines le marché de charlotte
s'arrête chez ses habitués dont civière
au chant à lac brome
ça se compare pas honnêtement avec ce
qu'on trouve l ipse on aime bien nos
épiciers
sauf que ce c'est vraiment une et
qu'elle a quelque chose superbe labrosse
c1
fromage de chèvre style de fromage à
tartiner mais au milieu vous avez toute
une couche de confit d'oignons ça avec
un morceau de pain super beau
[Musique]
alors cette semaine on a des aspects on
s'est approchés puis on a vu l'état
l'âge de clément puis sa passion à nous
raconter un peu l'histoire de chacun des
produits qui représentent donc ont été
charmés sur le coup on adjoint tout les
oppose aux là maintenant on réfléchit
plus à ce qu'on mange
je pense qu'on a beaucoup évolué et puis
ça devient un plaisir est encore plus
intense plus grand de cuisine et de
discuter aussi avec tous ces gens là qui
prennent le temps de faire les choses
avec ça demande beaucoup d'énergie
l'autre de cultiver et puis de faire les
choses les produits bio tout ça puis on
va garder cette habitude gosses c'est
clair ça fait vraiment partie maintenant
de notre vie
dix camions dit forcément des soucis
techniques des soucis mécaniques mais à
date je touche du bois
et au final ben ça roule ya aucun n'y
aucun problème ça roule ta bouche
[Musique]